[Musica]
qualche anno fa ho avuto un'idea per
documentare secondo me era un'idea
geniale e sono andata presentata al
canale televisivo
l'idea era quella di seguire i due
ragazzi cina un ragazzo che i denti che
è la disperata ricerca di una vacanza
testi ca per organizzare un matrimonio
finto e per farvi sui suoi genitori e
l'altra lega non sempre se c'era anche
una ragazza lesbica già sposata e quindi
a questo punto era la disperata ricerca
di un figlio perché i suoi genitori che
si devono certamente di procreare e
quando finirò la presentazione il
direttore del canale in quarta dice
canina molto carino queste però farmi un
attimo capire tu vuoi fare un
documentario in cina per un canale a
tante se vivi a londra e sei italiano e
se quelle soldi da me
a quel punto questa cosa mi piace molto
a riflettere prima di tutto fare che non
sarei mai riuscito a fare il film che
avremmo voluto e poi mi fece un po
riflettere su uno stile di vita sul mio
stile di vita e quello comunque i miei
colleghi
io sono una documentarista una regista
di documentari e come i miei colleghi
del parco della mia vita fino per
consegnare un certo numero di case e per
il canale intervento in senso anti tutto
ciò che citavo senso di appartenenza
e questo in realtà può essere una città
può essere una
nazione può essere una stile di vita e
finiamo quindi per diventare una su una
sorta di magico derby continua ma in
carriere case molto di frequente ma
perché è importante essere nomadi nostro
pari documentatissima in generale
e com'è che questo poi va a cambiare la
percezione delle serre
allora prima di tutto diciamo che quando
uno di noi nasce cresce dell'interno
circolo cerchio sociale e culturale
lasciare una certa famiglia in un paese
che sono partite sul campo sociale se
non usciamo anche fuori del nostro del
nostro cerchio
se rimaniamo all'interno di ciò che
conosciamo delle persone dice schemi di
conte le persone che ci assomigliano
rischiamo di atrofizzarsi e
l'immaginazione viene a mancare per cui
modo per uscire dal palchetto litorale e
quindi possiamo finire è quello di
pensando di mezzo a questo rilancio è la
narrazione di storie e le tramite le
storie che riusciamo ad avere una
visione del nastro e a volte quello che
vediamo un po anche finire perché cerci
come dicevo io frequento molti colleghi
sono persone che pagano su cui molto
hanno viaggiato in tutto il mondo
lavorato a madrid i tanti paesi diversi
rispetto al paese di origine e spesso
sento dire questo persone che
si sentono molto più a loro agio con i
loro colleghi che con le persone che
vengono dal paese della siccità e quindi
questa cosa spesso che ha fatto
riflettere se davvero questi motivi
abbiamo perso le nostre analisi
in realtà credo viste così piuttosto che
per delle pitture ci dobbiamo imparare
vivere tra mondi diversi casi diversi
boschi e riconosciamo come case e io
particolare viaggiando molto sono nate
crescita le giocate e poi sono andata a
vivere tonino bello fatto diversità ha
fatto ancora un anno di dottorato di
ricerca
poi sono andata giù del mondo dove sono
rimasta dove abili in questi nove anni
in realtà ho fatto tanto per pc in anas
e da me li sara dei tanti altri costi
perché il lavoro che faccio che io erano
dei centri di lavoro mi porta a pensare
è stato molto tempo nei luoghi e quelle
persone perché bisogna che sarà un
rapporto di fiducia e di mettere una
specie di amica di queste persone che
quindi devono aprirsi di fronte alle
telecamere e proprio perché di tipo di
promettere che faccio che si ferma
nell'osservazione cioè io l'ho sempre le
persone con data leggete loro storie si
sviluppino risolte alla telecamera
all'utilizzo interviste e quindi ho
davvero rispediti diventare un mostro di
servono vicino alle persone e per farlo
il pedinamento vi faccio vedere i tuoi
clip nella prima clip cerri la ragazza
lesbica chi non aveva detto ai genitori
di essere
essere gay e si focalizza proprio sul
rapporto tra genitori e figli le
difficoltà tra genitori e figli per cui
volevo chiaramente andare a firmare i
suoi genitori valutare da ottenere delle
scene stendete la difficoltà le
pressioni e le comprensioni con
creditori loro e quando glielo dissi per
i visti i rapporti che c'erano mi disse
silvia è riempito di cisco incontro
nasce il problema di proseguire i suoi
genitori e per questi termini dei
sostenitori è tutto il paesino nel
paesino sperduto in cina che eravamo lì
per forza di mettere sugli ambienti e
quindi il mio testo in altre agip
nell'altra vita del protagonista del
documentario man ha bisogno di gara di
introduzione se possibile andare i video
adesso grazie
la dolce
[Musica]
chicago
ok allora sì
manchester
anzi sembra simile all estero
purtroppo mancano cioè insomma il focus
aderito prezzo chiaramente abbiamo
mangiato chili e chili i gamberetti e
memoria è felicitato differenti potremmo
fare un intero documentario di
gamberetti perché appunto siamo tutti
stare moltissimo tempo caso di serri per
riuscire a ottenere queste immagini sono
stati di loro ci sono quasi dimenticati
della presenza della telecamera per
quanto riguarda è lì spesso non hanno
sposato nel caso in cui però se
scegliete quindi cosa succede una volta
vita alla storia bisogna passare la
storia successiva quindi la mobilità è
visto da alcune necessità è importante
muoversi per acquisire nuove conoscenze
conoscere nuovi personaggi come storie e
interessarsi e temi diversi
questo punto mary suo prima ci rende o
un altri punti normali moderni
continuiamo a muoverci e facciamo questo
fa sì che diventiamo delle persone che
non sono ditte non abbracciano una
[Musica]
appartenenza
questo questo stile di vita volta anche
delle cose negative chiaramente in
primis ray questo continuerà a muoversi
innamorarsi dei luoghi crisi basta ne fa
sì che lasciato un pezzettino di cuore
ognuno di questi luoghi el altro
problema è quello che spesso diventa
difficile definire cosa in casa del
congiunto di casa però abbiamo tutti
bisogno di avere una casa abbiamo
bisogno
milioni speri qualcosa in cui
identificati sia perché questo ci serve
per mantenere una visione la passione
perché ci sarebbe collegarci metterci e
con i nostri personaggi quindi lo
straniero è stato il pubblico con noi
stessi e alla fine ci vediamo porto che
avere un appartenenza cc liberati quanto
luci pestrin e quindi si giunge alla
conclusione che più che farà vivere
senza una casa o lontano da casa di
imparare a vivere tra case tra luoghi
luogo proviene in cui si è nati
cresciuti e ai luoghi in cui ci siamo
sentiti a casa questo dal punto di vista
emozionale veramente difficile perché
richiede di stare posto per un periodo
senza tante formalizzare anche
moltissimo chiede passare tempo con le
persone vicine ma essere vicina alle
persone lontane e spesso è molto
difficile riuscire a colmare vuoti tra
tra le case è però è anche un enorme
privilegio poter evitare così tante case
ed è un privilegio che il regista di
documentari condivide condivide
raccontando delle storie contro facendo
dei film e il fine ultimo è quello di
raccontare delle storie universali che
cono che impostano colmare le distanze
tra mondi che sono molto distanti tra di
loro è all'origine direttore del canale
quando un presentatore se all'inizio si
convinse il film ha fatto andando molto
bene e sta venuta in tanti paesi diversi
e questo mi piace pensare che appunto
siano spero diversamente di tutti
possano in qualche modo capisce
immedesimarsi nelle storie dei
personaggi del film e quindi torno al
fine ultimo di documentare poi non solo
i documentari in generale raccontare
storie sfrutta le storie importante
perché è quello che facciamo e uscire
dal nostro piccolo mondo ed esplorare
velocità fuori andare a conoscere quello
che è diverso da noi
[Applauso]